- So it's great to be here.
Thanks all for coming
to our presentation here
to talk a little bit about LocalStack
and developing service
applications on your local machine.
So maybe just a quick show of hands
before we dive into the agenda,
can we just get a quick
show of hands who has heard
about LocalStack before,
maybe even used it?
Okay, so there's about half of
the people here in the room,
so that's great.
So we're gonna keep it
relatively high level
and also wanna talk a bit
about the AWS partnerships
that we've been doing recently,
which is really exciting
to share with you all.
So this is the agenda we wanna go through.
I'm not gonna spend too much time here.
Let's dive right in.
So generally speaking, what is LocalStack?
We are a...
Imagine you have like
local AWS sandboxes, right?
Giving you the ability to develop
and test your applications
on the local machine
without being connected
to the cloud environment or
before connected to the cloud.
So what you see here is kind
of a traditional workflow.
You start with some
local environment, right?
Do some local testing,
maybe IDE integration,
then you run some tests
in the CI/CD environment,
and then finally you push
changes up to the real cloud
once you're happy with the
application you're developing.
So some of the benefits here you see is
that you get these instant feedback loops
by running things locally,
not having to push every
change into the cloud.
You have fully isolated test sandboxes
that run in your CI/CD process,
so no overriding of changes of each other.
And again, you ship to
production with confidence
once you're happy with the
changes you've made locally.
So there's more than
a hundred AWS services
that we have in our stack today.
So I think it's 120 at this point.
Everything from Lambda, SQS,
DynamoDB, IAM, you name it.
And we also integrate with most
of the existing
infrastructures, code tools,
you know, Terraform, CDK, you name it.
So we really try to meet the
developers where they are,
make sure that you can just
run new applications locally.
So how does it generally work, right?
So it's basically a docker
image if you spin up
as a container, right?
So you just basically install the CLI,
you say LocalStack start,
it spins up, you can see the
banner here in the terminal.
And then the second thing is
you just interact with it,
which basically just means
setting the AWS endpoint URL
to local host and then
you're off to the races.
You can just use the AWS CLI
and all your native tooling there.
So one of the questions
we often get is, okay,
how do we actually keep up with, you know,
the amazing pace of AWS and
all the great innovation
that's coming out there.
We heard many announcements at
re:Invent already this year,
so almost everybody visiting
our booth has this question.
So basically it boils down
to, you know, a couple of,
a combination of factors.
So first of all, we've built
a lot of internal tooling.
One of them is called ASF,
the AWS server framework.
So we do a lot of automated scraping
of the API specifications.
We always detect when there's
a new change coming out
with AWS services.
The second part is we
have a enormously talented
engineering community in-house
and also, you know, the
open source community.
So there's a lot of people just rambling
behind building these emulators,
which is a phenomenal effort really.
And then thirdly, what we're
gonna talk about today also is
there's more and more
partnerships going on specifically
with AWS, so we can do same day launches
and make sure that you actually get all
these great new features
in the local developer experience
once they're released by AWS.
So with that, I'm gonna
hand it over to Shridhar
and he's gonna share a little
bit from AWS perspective,
the serverless staff challenges.
- Thank you, Waldemar.
As we have discussed
LocalStack capabilities
and how it keeps pace with AWS services,
I want to shift our focus to...
There's some loud music
playing back there,
so if you hear any feedback,
just know it's not me.
We should shift our focus
to serverless developer challenges
serverless developers
face when they're building
serverless applications.
Now these challenges
represent the pain points
we are collaboratively addressing, right?
The AWS serverless team has been at work,
and particularly focused on improving
the developer experience,
which is why this
partnership is so valuable.
Let's start with the challenges.
Let's break it down into,
we break it down into four key areas
that affect serverless
developers on a daily basis.
The challenges significantly
impact productivity,
code quality, developer satisfaction,
and just the way the quality
of your overall application
when it comes to even things
like operational efficiency
and so on, right?
So we'll explore each of them in detail
in the upcoming slides.
The first is testing in the cloud.
You know, cloud-based
validation slows things down.
It slows down your duration cycles.
AWS research shows that developers
spend considerable amount
of time on their local devices
where they're, you know,
testing and writing code
rather than in, you know,
so what that means is it is critical
to get them going fast as soon
as possible to their stage
where they're able to see
what they're after building
what it looks like.
Now, each code change
requires a full cycle
if you're deploying to production,
so you have to go through
validation, testing, deployment,
and the feedback loops
could stretch anywhere
from minutes to hours.
This dramatically reduces
the developer productivity
and innovation velocity,
which is obviously not a good thing.
So what should be a quick
test usually becomes a cycle,
a lengthy process,
and this forces developers
to batch changes
or, you know, make educated guesses
rather than actually
relying on real validations.
The second challenge is context
switching between tools.
It comes with a significant
cognitive overhead
of constantly switching
between different tools.
Developers routinely
shift between IDEs, CLIs,
and resource emulators.
What this does is it creates
fragmented workflows,
and each context switch disrupts
what you're trying to build.
It interrupts your flow,
it reduces productivity.
Managing multiple tools increases
the likelihood of errors
and creates significant
mental overload as well.
Now this is particularly noticeable
in serverless development
where you're working
with multiple services,
for example, the likes of
Lambda, SQS, EventBridge,
API gateway, you name it.
There's always a myriad of services
that you are working together with,
and there this challenge
is the most pronounced.
The next is configuration
complexity, port mapping,
and code edit for local
service integration tests.
They introduce inconsistencies
between local and cloud environments.
Developers must maintain
separate copies of configuration
for local versus cloud, cloud
computing or cloud testing.
And this leads to the classic, you know,
"works on my machine" problem
that you've all run into at some point.
These manual configurations
are not only error prone,
they can be time consuming,
and it requires a
constant maintenance cycle
as applications evolve
and get bigger and bigger.
And the last one is,
and this one I want to
stress is super important
for serverless developers is integrations.
I touched upon multiple services earlier.
Integration testing is difficult, period.
Now, troubleshooting Lambda
functions in the context
of AWS service integrations
with DynamoDB, S3, SQS,
this requires complex setup.
And event driven architectures
can be particularly
challenging to test locally,
and what ends up happening
is developers resort to
"test in production" approaches,
and we all know that we
shouldn't rely on that.
So the hidden complexity
of service integrations
is much larger than the
function code itself,
and this creates a
significant testing gap.
So now that we understand the challenges,
let's look at the solutions LocalStack
and AWS develop together.
The collaboration between
AWS and LocalStack
addresses all these challenges
through a seamless
integration that brings best
of the both worlds.
In the next slide I'll talk
about how this simplifies
the experience of working on a local IDE,
and scan the QR code if you
want to read more about offline.
So the AWS toolkit for VS
code now integrates directly
with LocalStack.
We launched this integration
back in September.
This creates a unified
development experience.
The integration enables local
testing of Lambda functions
with full AWS service integrations.
It provides consistent behavior
between cloud and local environments,
and it eliminates the manual
configuration of service,
various service integrations
and service connections.
This results in accelerated
development cycles.
It reduces context switching
and it simplifies the
integration testing cycle,
and it also helps you
ascertain the code quality,
meaning that the code is of high quality
before you actually send it
to production integration testing,
or even staging environments.
And let's get more specific
first on what are the benefits.
I know that I talked about
addressing these challenges,
so let's talk about them.
So you get one-click
LocalStack setup directly
in your visual studio code IDE.
That means no more complex docker commands
or configuration file.
It's all handled for you.
The second thing is that you can access
all your emulated resources
directly from your VS code IDE.
This means that you get to stay
in your development
environment without having
to switch context between
multiple tools and interfaces.
You can also easily switch
between local and cloud
resources with a simple click,
making it seamless to test locally
and then deploy to the
cloud rather than deploy
to the cloud and then test.
So we are kind of reversing
the paradigm here.
And most importantly,
you get a dramatically
faster local feedback loop.
Changes that would take
minutes to test in the cloud
can be validated in seconds locally,
and this significantly accelerates
your development velocity.
With that said, let's take a
quick look at the live demo
that Waldemar is going to talk about.
- Awesome, thanks so much, Shridhar.
I just wanted to emphasize
we couldn't be more excited
to stand up here on the booth
or at the stand as LocalStack together
with the AWS Lambda team,
so it's a really exciting integration
for us all here to talk about this.
And we would've loved to show
you like an actual live demo,
but this is a recorded video
that I'm gonna play here,
and I'm gonna speak to it, it's
about a three minute video,
and we'll see what's going on there.
So basically what we're showing here is
the VS code integration that
Shridhar was talking about,
and we're gonna deploy a
simple sample application,
fully run it on LocalStack
via the AWS toolkit,
and then at the end
also show how you can do
breakpoint debugging
directly from the IDE.
So I'm just gonna kick off this video here
and speak to it a little bit.
I know it's pretty fast,
but let's just dive in
and see what it does.
So what we see here, we're
creating a new project here
that's called "LocalStack HelloWorld."
This is actually a SAM
service application template,
so it basically, you know,
renders a cloud transformation template
that you can directly deploy via SAM.
And the nice thing is you
could just take the whole thing
and deploy it against AWS,
you know, totally works out.
But what we're gonna do
here is we're actually doing
a SAM deploy and specify
the profile LocalStack.
The profile LocalStack is
just a local AWS profile
like any other.
The only thing is that we
actually define the endpoint
to be local host, right?
That's literally the only
difference that you see there.
So we're doing the SAM deploy,
specify a couple of parameters
like region, stack name,
and just the basic information.
This is all standard
AWS deployment, right?
But again, the deployment
is actually happening
against LocalStack.
So we see the stack resources here,
it's pretty snappy, which
is in a couple of seconds
everything is deployed,
and we see now we have an API gateway
with a Lambda function deployed
that's running fully locally.
This is our application web app,
app.localstack.cloud, if
you wanna give it a try.
It's a bit like the AWS console
where you can browse
your resources locally.
And this is the Lambda
function, which is created here.
And now we are actually
doing an invocation.
So at the bottom of the screen
you can see a curl command.
We're just doing a curl,
which is removing, replacing aws.com
with localhost.localstack.clouds.
Otherwise it's exactly
the same kind of endpoint,
and we see the invocation was done.
So we just is a full round
trip of an API gateway,
Lambda invocation that
connects to DynamoDB.
Now we're making some
changes in the Lambda,
which is, you know, change
the messages coming back here,
do another SAM deploy.
So this is basically just
redeploying the changes
we just made in the IDE.
And again, it's just gonna
take a couple of seconds.
It's doing the cloud formation updates
and we should be done in a second.
And then we're gonna run the
curl command one more time
and it'll show the updated output.
So now this is fairly,
what you've seen so far
is pretty much table stakes.
This is just LocalStack basics in a sense,
but now the exciting part is gonna come
for all those of you
familiar with LocalStack.
So what we're gonna show here now
is the remote debugging
capability in the AWS toolkit.
So what the toolkit
provides is effectively
a remote debugging where
you can set a break point
directly in the Lambda code.
And on the right hand side you see
the remote debugging configuration.
You can use that against AWS as well,
and also natively the same
experience against LocalStack,
so it's just literally the same experience
that you get there.
So we have the local endpoints,
we do the remote invoke,
and it actually, you know,
hits the break point right there.
We can make changes, we
can step over the code,
just the regular debugging
experience that you all used to
in your day to day work.
So that is, and then we see
the updated output in the end.
So that was a quick walkthrough.
I know that the video was pretty fast,
but hopefully we were able to
give you a bit of a glimpse
into the experience that you
have with the AWS toolkit
together with LocalStack.
And it's worth mentioning,
as Shridhar said,
no more need to configure any, you know,
docker composed files or complex setup.
It's all fully integrated.
It's just a turnkey
solution in that sense.
So with that, I just
wanna sort of close out
with just mentioning
again the partnerships
and the collaborations that we
are doing together with AWS,
which again is super exciting for us
as we're kind of growing
the open source community
and also our business.
So we have been launching in
the past already a couple of,
I think it was probably half a year ago,
also step functions testing
integration with LocalStack.
So there's actually a couple of features
that we're coming out in
step functions recently.
TestState API, JSONata
support, and Variables.
So for those of you using
step functions once in a while
or on a regular basis,
those are some really killer
features that AWS put out,
you know, some time ago.
And we basically were able
to do same day launches
together with AWS, right?
So we're partnering up very closely
with the folks over there to make sure
that all the good stuff that's coming out
is available to you like
in an instant, right?
TestState API I think is
actually that's something
very recent at re:Invent,
if I'm not mistaken.
- [Shridhar] A couple weeks ago.
- A couple weeks ago, yeah.
So that's just another example
even besides the toolkit
of the partnership
that's now taking shape more and more.
And there's more to come.
There was actually literally
at re:Invent a launch
around Lambda Managed Instances,
if you haven't seen the announcement
maybe you can check it out.
We also put out a blog post there.
And again, it was like a same day launch
we were able to do as we were very closely
partnering up with AWS.
The second part that we're
of course focusing on
on an ongoing basis is
just improved parity.
So we wanna make sure
that any stack you deploy
really has the high fidelity
that you would expect
from a local emulator.
And we're working very hard
together with our team,
with the community to
make sure that this is
a high fidelity, a digital twin
of your cloud environment, if you will.
And then the third one
is around, of course,
developer experience is
becoming a big, big topic.
Also, AI, it plays into
our day-to-day lives
of how we're building cloud applications.
So we are building sort of on top
of the emulator developer
experience features
to give you more debugging capabilities,
more insights into your stack,
debug your IM policies for
example, and much more.
And AI is also coming as a new means
of developing applications,
and we have a secure local
sandbox that you can, you know,
use for your agent decoding there.
So with that, wanna close out the session.
We have a couple minutes left,
but definitely wanna give a shout out.
Please visit us at our booth, 1626.
It's right over there.
Just literally behind the Redis booth,
you'll find the LocalStack booth.
We're gonna show you some live demo,
show you the AWS toolkit integration.
The team's gonna be there
to answer any questions you might have.
Again, we'd love to, you
know, get your feedback,
and see what's coming
out next at LocalStack.
Also, please do give us
feedback, that would be great.
So in the app you have a way
to provide feedback for the session.
If there is anything we can
improve or learn from it,
we always appreciate any
feedback you can share with us.
So with that, I'm gonna close.
And again, thank you so much
for your attention being here,
and very much looking
forward to everything
that's coming next in
local cloud development.
Thank you all.